you started your comedy career just up
the street from the Apollo Theater black
clubs I was doing because it's a solemn
so the difference then I moved down the
white clubs downtown there's a
difference a big difference a difference
doing white clubs and black gloves
cousin if you bomb in a white club that
the comedian's will talk crap about you
but they don't give me encouragement
like you'll get them that show but if
you bombing a black Club soon as you
come upstairs
they say kill yourself really kill
yourself
Wow that's pretty rough as the
neighborhood changed a lot since a is
Jutra five yeah
like when I came in white people was
loud hi JC that's a warm skin future
part that changed huh gentrified yeah
now you early on in your career you
performed at the Apollo is that right
yeah I remember I was right there I was
standing right there and I bombed you
bombed it didn't go well
no I started in that corner right up
there
I've had trouble with that same corner
tonight you know it's a part of the
theory where it's yeah she started shoot
the winner and I looked over in the sand
man was stretching yeah man he was
fooling to hook together yeah man
and he would take people out and so you
saw him getting ready to take you a boat
she wasn't gonna give me cuz I said
later for this and I ran off the stage
and I pushed her lucky log over and said
that wait why were they booing you did
you do a joke they didn't like what
happened something like that I got a
joke that first guy came on before me
was order was we go to unicycles he's
juggling and the crowd went crazy and I
was backstage right over that I said
imma follow him so when I came out and I
said you guys let the common unicycle
they said yeah I said my son died gonna
you recycle
Oh
[Music]
so but now you're back and look they
love you
you
you